quand le courage à un nom celui de
marina oficial ico va en plein journal
télé cette journaliste russe a brandi un
panneau contre la guerre en ukraine pour
ce geste elles risquent jusqu'à 15 ans
de prison cette censure des médias s'est
accentuée sous la présidence de vladimir
poutine et ça fait plus de vingt ans que
ça dure évidemment de mauvaises
démocratie évidemment c'est une
dictature tato 2001 vladimir poutine est
au pouvoir depuis quelques mois
seulement et déjà une chaîne de télé
indépendante mtv est dans son
collimateur si on dit la vérité sur
la corruption si on dit la vérité sur la
tchétchénie alors
le gouvernement le kremlin pense qu'il
s'agit de l'athletic ntv pas sous le
contrôle de l'état en 2001 dans les
médias le pouvoir est omniprésent ou
presque partout c'est une chasse aux
sorcières qui démarrent les gouverneurs
pratiquent la même méthode que le
président lé maire de granville
pratiquer les mêmes choses que les
gouverneurs nous conversons
l'autocensure je dois dire jaurès ont
peur de perdre leur travail c'est tout
certains journalistes sont
quotidiennement menacés et ça peut aller
beaucoup plus loin gare à ceux qui
critiquent l'entourage de vladimir
poutine et les fortunes parfois douteuse
des oligarques russes
paul klebnikov travaillait pour le
journal économique forbes en 2004 ce
journaliste américain d'origine russe
est tué à moscou à cause de ces enquêtes
une voiture vitres fumées suivez le
journaliste le chauffeur a baissé la
vitre et a tiré plusieurs fois sur lui
ce taureau deux ans plus tard en 2006 ce
nouvel assassinat d'une journaliste la
russe anna politovskaïa à moscou elle
aussi était très critique envers la
politique mené par vladimir poutine
je suis très choquée heureux c'était une
personne charmante pour l'une de ses
consoeurs c'est clair c'est une nouvelle
mise en garde du kremlin c'est une
nouvelle dévastatrice pour nous les
journalistes ce qui est clair c'est que
maintenant vont moins parler y est moins
ouvert sur ce que nous pensons et ce que
nous ressentons
2008 vladimir poutine n'est plus au
pouvoir c'est dimitri medvedev le
nouveau chef de l'état mais les
assassinats de journalistes se
poursuivre 2009 la journaliste
ukrainienne anastasia babourova est
assassiné
tout comme natalia estemirova cette
journaliste et militante russe des
droits de l'homme et sauvagement
assassinés en russie de choses elle
était l'âme ou sur l'âme de notre
travail l'âme de notre organisation ils
ont tué notre âme je ne sais pas comment
nous allons travailler maintenant
depuis d'autres journalistes opposé à la
politique de vladimir poutine sont morts
assassinés pour 2021 la russie occupe et
la 150e place sur 180 au classement
mondial de la liberté de la presse un
chiffre publié par l'organisation non
gouvernementale reporters sans
frontières
[Musique]